" Je n’ai pas, monsieur le député,
je n’ai jamais eu
de compte à l’étranger,
ni maintenant, ni avant. "
Devant un hémicycle plein à craquer,
il dit cette phrase et
beaucoup de députés vont le croire.
La revanche sera d’autant plus terrible,
c’est que les députés,
sûrement, dans la rudesse
de leurs questions
lui feront payer ce mensonge
devant la représentation nationale.
On est quand même
dans le temple de la République
et on a un ministre,
ministre du Budget
qui ment sur son compte en Suisse.
" - Il a sciemment menti
à la représentation nationale.
Cet acte est inqualifiable.
- C’est un discrédit complet,
mais au discrédit
il ajoute le déshonneur. "
Est-ce que quelqu’un à l’Elysée,
à Matignon, chez les ministres
savait qu’il avait
un compte en Suisse?
C’est ce versant politique
qui va beaucoup animer les auditions.
" Jérôme Cahuzac est convoqué
devant la commission,
extirpé de sa longue retraite. "
Jérôme Cahuzac, on ne l’a pas vu
pendant trois mois.
Depuis la passation de pouvoir,
depuis qu’il a quitté Bercy,
il s’est caché.
Personne ne l’a vu, il est quasiment
comme en cavale journalistique.
" - Je voulais savoir si vous regrettez
ce mensonge du 5 décembre dernier?
- Je vous ai menti en
vous répondant Monsieur le député
tout simplement parce que
dans les heures qui précédaient
j’avais menti au Premier ministre
et au Président de la République. "
Toutes les chaînes vont retransmettre
les 2 heures d’audition de Jérôme Cahuzac.
La force de LCP, c’est de retransmettre
toutes les auditions ou presque.
Les députés vont auditionner Médiapart
évidemment, qui a sorti l’Affaire.
Ils vont auditionner les ministres,
Christiane Taubira, Pierre Moscovici.
" Le mot «associé» pour le coup,
Monsieur le Président,
je connais votre finesse
sémantique, est impropre.
Jérôme Cahuzac n’a pas été associé
à cette demande en quoi que ce soit. "
Le plus virulent de tous,
c’est Charles de Courson
qui est le président de
cette commission d’enquête.
" - Vous pensez qu’une réponse
est crédible
qui consiste à dire:
je ne me souviens plus d’une réunion
qui a eu lieu en janvier
de cette année?
Cette amnésie ne vous paraît
pas peu crédible?
Ça veut dire que vous contestez
les propos de Monsieur Pierre Moscovici?
- Ça veut dire que nous n’avons
pas les mêmes souvenirs,
c’est un peu différent. "
L’Affaire Cahuzac et
la commission Cahuzac,
c’est un marqueur
de l’histoire parlementaire.
Si aujourd’hui un ministre
n’est pas nommé
sans qu’on ait
épluché son patrimoine,
c’est parce qu’il y a eu
l’Affaire Cahuzac.
Donc, pour LCP, avoir été
aussi présent sur cette affaire,
avoir pu faire
des auditions en direct,
avoir pu décrypter
tout ce qui s’est passé
et le rôle qu’ont eu les députés
en étant sur cette affaire et
d’une certaine façon,
rendant justice aux Français,
en posant des questions
que tout le monde pouvait se poser,
eh bien nous on était
très content d’avoir fait ça,
vraiment, vraiment content.